hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream A and Q segment we
are ready to rock and roll apparently
we're not interesting enough for Fairfax
to stick around you know cats yeah yeah
can't live without them nope
um
all right we are going to start as we
always do with a question from the
Discord server this week they had a tie
so they proposed two questions to us but
one of them I see is actually
um closely matched with a question that
came in on Dark Horse submission so I'm
gonna go with the one that's not a match
and then uh we have one from another
another friend who made a special
request and um
and then we'll get into the questions
from Dark Horse submissions we got cat
fight going on the background there okay
first question can you elaborate
yes at Lane I can also extrapolate and
sometimes I like to mix and match the
two thank you yeah extrapolate right
elaborate
exactly yeah oh boy okay can you
elaborate on what's wrong with the food
pyramid and do you know of a source that
clearly lays out the history of
corruption and errors and nutrition
guidelines it seems like they've
improved a lot in recent years but are
still pretty poor
um I let's just start with the easy part
um which is that the I don't know part I
don't know of a source that lays out the
history of corruption and errors but I'd
be very interested in in that um I would
hope that there is some absolutely
fantastic book out there uh and so if
there is if you guys figured out tell us
I'd be very interested in knowing that
um with regard to it seems like they've
improved a lot in recent years which are
still pretty poor
I'm not going to remember where it was
but I just saw a new set of
recommendations
um put out by you know this University
that University the head of the
something something FDA I don't remember
um
that ended up
this got a lot of like social media
plays so maybe a couple weeks ago uh
ended up if you followed what they
actually said
um clearly you were better off basically
eating like Cheetos and wheat bran than
you were eating steak and eggs
uh which is [__] right uh so the the
problem now for sure is a combination of
a history of wrong upon wrong upon error
upon error upon wrong and so it's hard
for almost anyone who's in the system to
imagine that actually what we have to do
is scrap the entire thing and and
rethink it all but also you just have
the perverse incentives again with
regard to you know who's paying the
bills and so you know what is it like
General Mills there's a few Giant food
producers who make most of their money
with the value-added products so it's
not that they're making most of their
money by selling wheat they're making
most their money by selling you know
Frosted Flakes or something and
um and if they're helping fund a bunch
of the research that's being done well
the research isn't going to really be
good research probably
so then none of that got to the first
part of the question but we'll riff a
little bit here well
I'm I'm just stumped by it because it's
a classic case of what could possibly go
right right you have a governmental body
that is going to make recommendations
based on health that are going to affect
how much of various competing products
are purchased
and no protection that would keep
corruption from using that to adjust
what happens and so yeah all I would say
is look
among the many ways that governmental
power is going to be abused are anything
that looks like a mandate is going to be
very tempting to anything that would
like its product forced onto people and
anything that looks like standard of
care is going to be irresistible and in
this case you have something that is
somewhere in between right to the extent
you've got a food pyramid it's going to
affect school lunches it's going to
affect advice and uh so the point is
you're an ape with a history an
evolutionary history that evolutionary
history has been disrupted by modernity
what you want to do is correct for the
distortions of modernity but you can't
possibly expect a system in which
literally tens of billions of dollars
are at stake based on the recommendation
given by a fallible corruptable body
um
it's going to be abused in exactly the
way that we know it to have been abused
right it's going to recommend things
that aren't good for you in order that
you will override
your own personal trepidations about
them and so it
uh
I guess the point is people frequently
ask us for oh well how could we fix the
system which is how can we how can we
fix higher ed
um well you could burn the system that
you have to the ground and then you
could think about how not to repeat
those errors but I think the point is
reform
of systems that are this badly captured
is not going to happen a they have an
immune system that will fend off your
attempts at reform
and B you haven't figured out how to
solve the fundamental problem of
banishing corruption and so uh I think
the point is the food pyramid is Dead on
Arrival you're really going to take
advice here's my feeling okay job number
one
I will not accept any food
recommendations from somebody who does
not give me a clear statement on the
number of sexes there are and how you
can tell okay
point is look you are asking something
that has told you that it is
scientifically incapable to give you
recommendations on what to eat
okay that's what you're doing it's also
going to give you recommendations on
um what to allow yourself to be injected
with and how that compares to your
actual immune system and its ability to
fend off viruses and the point is no it
keeps telling you in a hundred different
ways that it isn't interested in science
that it isn't capable of doing good
science that it is simply interested in
doing the bidding of interests that you
don't know and can't see and so I don't
know as far as I'm concerned food
pyramid's Dead on Arrival and I'm
ashamed that I didn't spot that as a
child because it should have been
obvious back then that this was going to
be a corrupted mechanism and anybody
who's missed it at this point is just
not paying attention Okay well that's
all very well and good but it doesn't
actually address the question of what's
what's wrong with it you asked you
answer the question of like what's wrong
with the formulation of having one but
as as per what's in it so I'd like to
spend a few minutes talking about that
so I look I look I looked it up and as
as much as huffpo has obviously become a
ridiculous thing in recent years the
first thing that I found while you were
talking that looks halfway reasonable is
a 2016 article I get my our ability to
display my screen isn't working so
um they they have it doesn't matter they
have a bunch of these from around the
world uh and that they have you know
China's food Pagoda they call it maybe
they actually call it that in China I
don't know this feels like a huffpo
thing
um
and they have one from the UK
France I'm guessing yeah France is going
to be a little bit different they do a
better job than most of these but almost
all of them so this is the this is the
perfect example right here Hungary is
house food guide and the US looks
similarly ridiculous
um has
um cereals at the bottom vegetables and
fruits meats and milk sharing like a
weird little rooftop space and then
sugar and fat as the chimney so the idea
is that you you should have the most of
the stuff on the bottom
and less as you go up and I think I I
think the reason that cereals shows up
which it's you know it's going to be a
different cereal depending on what part
of the world you're in if you're in Asia
it's most likely to be rice if you're in
you know the UK it might be potatoes and
it's going to be sorghum in some places
quinoa in some places whatever it's
going to be some
um you know seed of a monocot of a grass
usually that has been through intensive
agricultural
um
practice over thousands of years made
into a crop that can easily be uh
harvested and then turned into something
that has a little bit of staying power
in terms of you know beer or bread
um you could you can carry it around
um
that was an incredible Innovation for
humans to be able to farm and then to be
able to make uh to turn these once
widely dispersed what we now call cereal
crops uh into a thing that we could
reliably know where to go and they are
full of uh energy but they are not the
best thing for us and at least in
America I I I imagine Maybe I'm Wrong
that most of our viewers and listeners
are plenty well fed and if anything if
you've got an issue it's more likely to
be you have access to more food than you
need and it's a question of keeping
yourself from from
um from from going there as opposed to
not having enough calories in a world
without enough calories cereals um can
be a godsend but in a world where
there's plenty of calories putting
cereals at the bottom at the foundation
of a food pyramid doesn't make sense
meat milk if you can accommodate if
you're from a lineage and are an
individual who can accommodate dairy
products are great as well but meat and
um some fruit some vegetables and some
fat should be should be the things that
you are you are building your your diet
on and you know do you do I just picked
on hungry here but they've got sugar and
fat together linked together there as
the as the top of the the chimney of the
House of the food pyramid
that's ridiculous sugar and fat are like
the opposite some terms of
um what they can do for you in your diet
and whether or not you should be eating
them
so I don't get it though it still seems
to me like
you know what is the geometrical
solution to food
it doesn't have a geometrical solution
right well but can you can you critique
you know maybe it's maybe it's an
octagon and it shouldn't be a pyramid
yeah maybe or maybe it's not a
geometrical problem
so I still think the basic point is
to critique this particular method is
you know like trying to you know
describe how to properly divide your
time based on the ratio of different
types of roads to drive on and you know
I mean surely you can understand the
question to be a broader one of like
okay I've heard a lot about it not being
good but then what should we be eating
right but what should we be eating I
would rather say look
read Michael pollen there's actually
advice in there that can be
operationalized and doesn't
try to dumb things down to a geometrical
structure that is easy to color code but
the point is you'll actually learn
something about food and you'll learn
something about your ancestors and I
guess
for me at this point
I am so done with the
simplified formulations designed to
trick me into doing something that 15
years from now I will understand was not
in my interest
right I'm just done with it I'm so I
guess my point is if a nutritionist is
pointing a pyramid at you that
nutritionist is into Pyramid Power and
the answer is no thank you I'm not
interested in your your mystical view of
food I'd rather go with some common
sense and uh you know and I can get it
from somebody who's willing to speak to
me in plain English rather than pretend
that I need it color coded right so I
was I was going to let you have the last
word there but like you you invoke
common sense and I think part of part of
what
this question is asking you what a lot
of people are asking is like okay but
I've been so befuddled I've been so lied
to I know I've been lied to I know I've
been getting really bad advice for a
long time such that I don't know what
common sense sounds like I don't know
what I'm supposed to be doing I would
like to
re-educate myself reinform myself my gut
my palate all of it sufficiently that I
can then be driven by what my body is
telling me to pursue but until and
unless I can get over some hump that's
between me and there it's not going to
be that easy okay so I think you're
being a little harsh no I'm I'm really
not being harsh enough no honestly I
mean I I'm I am at my Wit's End
I'm sorry you're being harsh on the food
pyramid I'm saying you're being harsh on
the audience
I'm trying to tell them like it is right
you could have we used to eat a lot more
grains than we do now you could recently
you could imagine somebody who was you
know
open to the possibility of the pandemic
having been mismanaged but not really
over in Dark Horse space right
you could imagine them saying okay but
let's just look at the cdc's advice
how can we make it better and the answer
is no no this person did not ask how can
we make it better well no see that's
what's wrong with your responding to a
question didn't get asked the question
is what's wrong with it right that's a
different question how can we make it
better what's wrong with it is it
it's the whole thing the question what
should it be what's good advice it
shouldn't be a pyramid uh it could be it
should be replaced with a free copy of
Michael pollan's book The omnivores
dilemma sent to every citizen okay
Omniverse dilemma is fantastic
um I taught with it when it came out
but it doesn't and you know the book
that comes out after that
um is a little bit closer to what you're
talking about the universe dilemma
doesn't do this at all he talks about
what real food looks like but he does so
by like going boar hunting in Contra
Costa county in California right and by
visiting uh whatever the awesome dude's
name is who does like the chicken
tractor in in on the East Coast
um and you know he he experiences some
you know he he goes and looks at real
honest food production
um and some you know massive
monopolistic you know mono cropping food
production as well but it's it's not
it's not a manual right but there isn't
a manual right this might be this is
what I'm this is what I'm trying to say
is
there is a
there is a reform mindset about taking
things that aren't good and making them
better and we are so far past the
utility of this mindset that I'm really
look again I just think you're
misreading the question I think you're
responding to something didn't get asked
Maybe
maybe but I think I'm responding with
the answer the fast forward answer but
if the if the question how can we fix it
the question is okay okay I get it it's
broken so what's not broken okay what's
not broken is the idea that you are a
creature with evolutionary metabolic
expectations living outside of your
ancestral environment okay you could
take something you know useful advice
for Michael pollen
stay out of the middle of your
Supermarket right that's an
operationalizable piece of advice that
doesn't it's not geometric and he's got
another one right which so he writes the
book I think it's like 2008 so just
correct it for time-ish
um and how old you might have been when
you were reading it um if your
grandmother wouldn't have recognized it
as food it's not food right that's
another one that he that he gives right
right
um eat food not too much mostly plants
okay also operationalizable yeah and I
don't I don't agree with that one at
this well you may not but the point is
it is already even if it's not perfect
how do we fix Michael pollan's advice
would be better that's a real question
how do we fix advice you're stuck on how
do we fix you're railing against the how
do we fix mentality and you keep
returning to it and I mean I gave
something of an answer already but like
I I think the person asking the question
I think most of us are interested in
figuring out okay forget forget the
broken system then let's talk about what
we should be doing
right I mean and you know of course we
do this in our book we talk a lot about
this stuff and it's also we do and we
actually I somehow
forgotten that yeah we do an entire
chapter on food right and diet and one
of the things we start in that chapter
is
um you know look at all the sort of fad
diets out there right now you know
there's the grapefruit diet there's
there's the paleo diet there's this that
and the other there's a Mediterranean
diet
um some of these diets are stupid like
grapefruit diet is not going to be good
for you long term I'm sure you can
survive for a week unless you're already
anorexic but like you know just don't
um but you know to some degree within
reason some you know if it if it is
borrowing from a tradition that exists
in the world if if the Mediterranean
diet whatever exactly that specifies
really does match how some people who
live in Greece say eat then
um then that's going to be healthy for
some people in the world is it
guaranteed to be healthy for you no
because you may not have have enough
Greek in you to match whatever exactly
that's doing so you know by and large
especially in America we're mutts and so
we got a lot of different things going
on in terms of what we probably can get
away with eating but obviously the diet
of the Maasai and the diet of the Inuit
are very very different and you can't
just tell it anyway like oh just eat the
Mediterranean diet it'll be great for
you it's like there's a decent chance
that's not going to work out as well
yeah I think I am you know you are
detecting the end of my patience with
um bad people who oversimplify things
because part of the part of the thing
about a rubric that is salable is that
it's simple enough to remember and so
they're using that to bypass reason and
frankly
you need to eat
real food you need to avoid using huge
volumes of stuff that are being used to
fill you up right and probably most
important on the list if you get down to
something that looks like a diet that
somebody has eaten in you know 500 years
ago looked like a diet you get to that
thing the biggest remaining issue is
how was your food produced right yeah is
it full of pesticide residues that the
FDA is going to swear are not a Hazard
To Your Health but is going to give you
Parkinson's and 20 years from now we
will be having that discussion about how
you got Parkinson's and how it wasn't
really about the content of what you
were eating but it was about the
residual stuff that got mixed in there
that didn't change the nutritional
aspect of it one bit right so there's
that there's the
um selecting of particular strains for
reasons that are not health or transport
yeah transport of mangoes transport
stability all these things right so
industrial agriculture is bad for you
for all kinds of reasons and the the
food pyramidization of the question is
part of the problem right
it's it's simply a debt on arrival
mechanism I guess maybe I'm not I don't
remember really ever running into the
food pyramid as a kid so it didn't it
didn't Loom large for me ever uh so for
me they exist a sort of separate like
the food pyramid seems to me like a a
stupid wrong-headed dead end as opposed
to sort of central to this whole to all
of this and I you know maybe it is maybe
clearly it's being used as a tool
um by a lot of people so I I don't know
if Zach has wanted to say something for
a little bit are you miked I can't be
yeah it's okay I think more core than
the food pyramid which is just sort of
some brand of visual that like I've sort
of barely seen it but I think some
people may be well familiar with it the
idea of a balanced diet is the most core
problem that there's nothing inherently
you should we I think the way I think
about it is that we've been given a gift
effectively of being omnivores we can
eat anything right I mean you can't
really eat trees but you can eat kale
but it's probably it's hard to get a lot
out of it right
and if you eat only salads every day you
can live and you'll be sort of healthy
but that's not
you know that stuff isn't very
easy to get much energy out of it if you
stop pretending that everything is
equally good for you in the right
proportions and
think about the way that you feel after
you eat a steak and a salad and a bowl
of fruit in each of those yeah the way
you feel after a day after each of those
and an hour after each of those
you will stop waiting each type of food
as equally beneficial because
we are
though most people have so much access
to really really good food for them and
also so much access to really terrible
food for them and everything in between
the idea that everything is equally good
for you and you should have a plate with
10 of each of those 10 things
destroying everyone yeah but this is
this is again this is effectively what
I'm saying is that it is misphrasing the
problem and pretending to simplify when
in fact it's not it's not a
simplification it's just wrong and I
think maybe that's
that's what's getting me is
when somebody presents something like a
food pyramid or a food Pagoda or
whatever the Hungry House thing was
right what they are doing we have
Japan's spinning top the spinning top
what they are doing is they are oh
Germany went 3D
they are pretending that this is the
following kind of problem there's a
tremendous amount of nutritional
information and I'm not going to burden
you with it it's a diminishing returns
problem so here's the thing if you've
got only a minute and a half here's the
pyramid and the point is no what you
just told me was that you were going to
give me the broadest brush strokes and I
was going to get the biggest bang for
the buck for what you're telling me and
if I want to get more detailed and
pursue smaller and smaller profits I can
get more and more nuanced and closer and
closer to literature but
the diagram you just gave me is wrong
you told me you were simplifying it and
that I was going to leave some profit on
the table but I was going to get a lot
of bang for the buck because it was only
going to take me a minute to understand
then you told me something dead wrong
and so it's the thing that tells you
something dead wrong while pretending
that it is a simplification that has got
to go
feel like we've seen that pattern
sometimes in the last three years this
is kind of my point is it's that same
that same thing it's doing it to us yep
fair enough
can I say one more thing yes just
continuing on what I just said
um
I would suggest never feeling bad about
having a meal that is like one thing
like if you have a steak or a bowl of
eggs or something that is
a full meal even if it's not even if you
don't have your
five percent of sugar and your whatever
else and you know you have a little bit
of carbs with it or whatever and that
can be good you can have a meal with
some mixed stuff but if you have a full
meal that's just a bunch of beef or
something that's one example that I'm
particularly fond of but if you have
something that is just a core thing as
your meal that's not a problem if it's
good for you I agree and it may actually
limit the amount that you eat because if
you eat a bunch of things I no no no no
I have the uh well this is maybe just me
I think most Americans don't share this
but I end up not eating enough I end up
eating like a meal a day if I don't
force myself to eat more if I eat steaks
I will easily go through like four
steaks a day and I feel better and I
grow and well but that's probably the
result of a different phenomenon which
is that you probably because it is one
thing and it's not just one thing at a
meal it's one thing at many meals you
are probably deficient in things that
are there in Trace Amounts and therefore
in order to get up to a non-deficient
amount you're probably I don't I don't
know about that I don't I feel healthier
in every way when I do right but you are
also eating all of those steaks so the
point is something in you is
compensating but I was going to validate
your earlier point if you think about it
because you don't know what Zach looks
like which is almost everyone uh he is
fit and lean and strong I would not say
he looks like almost everyone but did I
say he looks like what did I say no you
said almost everyone doesn't know what I
look like
but what I was going to say is if you
think about a hunter-gatherer in a
hunter-gatherer world that individual
happens on you know a thing at a time
and it's not like they put together a
balanced meal it's like oh we need some
chair neck with our giraffe go get some
chair right
you want ten percent Sharon okay
um but you know you happen onto a bush
full of berries and you eat berries or
you happen onto nuts that you can eat
and you eat nuts or you happen to have
made it but this is my point we have the
gift of being able to digest all of
those things we also have the gift right
now in modern society of having access
to like the perfect Foods in addition to
all of the worst foods you could
possibly come up with but we have access
to like the things that our ancestors
would dream of being able to have for
every meal if I could have a steak every
meal yeah eggs like fresh eggs or yeah
raw dairy or like just like all of the
stuff all of the time it's like they
would never consider eating like
scrounging for leaves and such because
it's just you can survive off of it
unless there's a question of Trace
nutrients right there's a question of
um whether or not steak and eggs can
actually well but this is part of what
yeah absolutely everything most
perfectly we don't like eating
carnivores you know omnivores get or you
know herbivores get a lot of that a cow
gets a lot of what's in grass and only
mostly what's in grass so don't eat a
lot of other stuff but you know you get
that through animals and if you're
eating a cheetah you get a lot less of
that because they're
it's twice digested so don't eat
cheaters I mean
among other reasons yes well I am I'm
tempted to push back on your disagreeing
with my agreement of you earlier but I
think in the interest of time we should
actually just move on to the next
question I think probably so yes
um so this um
I'm just going to read it this this
comes this actually comes from a friend
so we're doing something we don't know
really do inserting between the Discord
question and the questions from the Q a
um this is from someone um who is
Ukrainian
in Ukraine Russian private military
contractors are using convicts often
ones that would never pass a proper Army
Medical for example a number of HIV AIDS
and Hep C infected convicts have been
denied as pows by Ukrainian forces and
the number of dead with these conditions
is unlikely to be zero
since Russia isn't keen on collecting
their War debt I should have to think
how many others with communicable
diseases are now bodies left to Decay
and be picked apart by animals in the
Ukrainian fields and forests what kind
of environmental impacts would
potentially arise out of this could HIV
learn to jump between say dogs and
humans there are some overweight stray
dogs in some of the hot spots
how would this affect the soil water
quality in the surrounding areas can you
Riff on this Grim reality
in reality I had no idea about yeah it's
pretty Grim my guess would be
very little in terms of communicable
diseases very few things are going to
learn to jump new hosts this way right
that so the likelihood of something from
an infected conscripted Soldier dying on
a battlefield making it into Wildlife or
even less likely into another person
directly is a pretty low chance now I
would want somebody who's expert in this
to think about the range of conditions
there may be a condition yeah that could
jump like a particular temperature
humidity time since death mode of
exposure is that what you mean by
condition for a pathogen that jumps from
corpses a particular pathogen and in
general people often leap to the
conclusion that the special way that
human cadavers smell
is a protection against the pathogens
that they had leaping to other people
and this has been repeatedly difficult
to demonstrate I don't think it's the
reason that human cadaver spell smell
special I think there is it is an
evolutionary warning but if something
very different and
anyway so my point would be
most pathogens are adapted to you stay
away and do not eat are distinct like it
goes in the same direction but they're
but they're different levels of
intensity right yeah the pathogen that
is adapted to you in life that is
adapted to jump between living humans is
not well adapted to jump from a cadaver
right a flea is different right a flea
on a dying or dead animal leaping to
another living animal that's uh
ectoparasites can do this right yeah but
a pathogen is unlikely again there are
ways consuming a cadaver changes the
Paradigm
um and there may be pathogens that are
particularly good at this but in general
I don't think you're liable to have a
Environmental
impact
um
from this nor do I would I expect
communicable diseases uh to change their
density on the other hand
if you have infected people
sent to war across a border
uh you have all kinds of other things
that could happen they could they could
end up
transmitting those diseases in the
normal ways that people end up
transmitting diseases you know right
rape happens during war right could a
hepatitis infected Soldier uh who's been
conscripted by the Russians no I mean
it's it's a kind of like simultaneously
biological and chemical warfare right
and so anyway it's not that there's no
issue here but I don't think the issue
is necessarily from the dead and I'd be
very curious if there was
a particular pathogen that
violated the rule I'd like I'd like to
know what it is or might evolve in that
direction under circumstances well it's
a pretty small opportunity yeah it is
it's not a huge number of good hours and
so
um you know it's
even the technical possibility of such a
thing evolving it's not a very well
constructed gain of function experiment
so I don't really expect it
surely not what Russia was up to
making a good gain of function
experiment there
all right
would a wife who wants to keep her man
happy by having frequent sex with him be
working against her interests pushing
him towards addiction to the love him
and leave him strategy
I'll read it again yes yes what a wife
who wants to keep her man happy by
having frequent sex with him be working
against her interests pushing him
towards addiction to the love of and
levo strategy oh I get it again no no no
no but
um I mean I guess
it seems like there's built into the
question an assumption
um
that she doesn't want to be having sex
and that anytime
a man is having a lot of sex it's
necessarily not with a long time partner
I think those are two assumptions built
into the question which aren't valid
inherently yeah yeah I see it the same
way
um and what's more there's just
something intuitively wrong with the
idea that
um a guy uh having sex at home
frequently would be more incentivized to
seek sex with other partners elsewhere
rather than less incentivized which just
seems wrong yeah yeah because presumably
he can still tell it's the same person
foreign
you know I mean even if they're like in
different rooms
[Laughter]
better smart this way they can actually
well thank you I think
okay
um
oh this is another this is a reminder
um I mentioned a while back about Dr Ken
Berry a big fan of yours doing an
interview with you about your book and
related I think you tried to contact you
recently hope you get to connect thank
you for all you do I sort of vaguely
remember this I have not seen an
attempted contact
UM
maybe encourage that to come through
come through again we've recently got an
improvement in in staff that may help
that may help with us
okay
what do you make of the hypothesis made
by JJ kui that much of the covert
phenomenon could have been created with
infectious clones and faulty PCR testing
that picked up background coronaviruses
um haven't delved deeply I will say I
intuitively the problem is not having
delved deeply I don't want to say I
don't think it's right because really
it's the kind of idea that requires uh
careful consideration I don't want to
dismiss it based on what I think he's
saying rather than what he's actually
saying yeah and there's no dummy so
right but however
um a look the PCR thing happened we
watched them game faulty PCR just faulty
PCR testing well we don't we know that
it picked up background coronaviruses we
don't know that but we know that they
Amplified it to the point that it wasn't
actually getting a lot of false
positives I mean let's when I finally
came to understood understand this
problem the Cycles yeah the idea is oh
you've got a machine in a hospital where
there's definitely covid and you've
turned the cycle threshold up so that
it's amplifying the tiniest you know
stray fragment and it's like oh well
okay yeah I get why those two things you
know presumably you can't turn the cycle
threshold up and get false positives if
there's nothing but in an environment
where there will be a little something
well that seems to me to be a part of
this that I don't know you know picked
up background coronaviruses now it I
would have thought that the PCR would
have been precise enough that you know a
background chronovirus wouldn't have
done it but I don't know
know either what I don't get is why
I think there is covet I think it's a
real thing and I think it was modified
in a laboratory and I understand I think
the argument why JJ believes
um that gain of function research in
general shouldn't be a very potent
technique I get that but I don't think
uh I don't think it negates what was
done here or seems to have been done
here and the viability of that thing
once in the human population as for what
it is that is actually circular
circulating
whether or not the named variants are
meaningful I remember being puzzled at
the beginning of the pandemic right it's
like oh a mutation is arisen
yeah that probably happens like 700 000
times an hour right each one of these
things right if you really zoomed in on
the phylogeny of all of these particles
right you would have a constant uh
modification right and so what exactly
are we talking about you know how big a
modification does it have to be before
you spot it and name it right so I do
think that there I think there's likely
to be a lot in what uh JJ kui says about
um swarms it's a place I've thought he's
been way ahead and it's meaningful but I
don't uh of what I've heard of where he
takes this analysis yep I'm skeptical
foreign
as a nurse I feel the game theory that
hospitals follow involves the hospital
with the lowest denominator of resources
gets the maximum profit and wins the
game
PT safety be damned
I have to read this question again this
seems to be a common theme in U.S
business for instance Frito-Lay
does Game Theory have an answer to this
or is it always a race to the bottom
yeah try it again
denominator isn't the right word here
as a nurse
feel the game theory that hospitals
follow involves the hospital with the
lowest denominator of resources getting
the maximum profit and winning the game
patient PT is going to be patient safety
be damned so I think rather than the
denominator I think it's just going to
mean um
yeah just like the hospital that spends
the less lease gets the most profit and
wins the game patient safety be damned
yep this seems to be a common theme in
the US business for instance Frito-Lay I
don't know the Frito-Lay example I mean
I know what Frito-Lay is but I don't
know particular example there does Game
Theory have an answer to this or is it
always a race to the bottom
um yeah Game Theory certainly has an
answer if I understand what's being
suggested here which is that you
create a race to the Bottom by creating
a game in which those who figure out how
to slash their own costs whether that's
because patients die or whether because
you deny them treatment that they need
yeah right
um you come out ahead and so the system
begins to look more and more like you
and your version of the game
right the obvious way to deal with that
you know let's say that you uh had a
all-cause mortality measurement across
different hmos and the point was the HMO
with the lowest all-cause mortality got
a financial payoff a windfall that was
large enough to beat the cost cutting
route to savings then and so and and but
then you also have to put a protection
against them not letting people in right
well right and so the point is how many
of these things do you have to stack
right before what you've done or do they
just do they close down their ERS well
but this this is this is the question of
good governance yes what is the minimal
structure in which the best way to win
the game is to accomplish the thing that
the system is designed to actually do
like increase human health right right
what you want is any cheating results in
you doing worse not better yeah no and
before so maybe the Frito-Lay example is
like this but I'm thinking about like
appliances
right what we as consumers want
if we have any flexibility in our
spending is to be able to spend a little
bit more now and have an appliance that
will definitely last for 15 years yep uh
as opposed to
oh you can spend as much as you want or
as little as you want but the thing's
going to fail in four okay
um
actually my values are that I want one
that's going to last for longer yep no
that's not on the table I want one
that's going to last for longer I want
one that when it fails I can buy the
part if it's failed because one part has
failed and I can spend two hundred
dollars rather than a thousand dollars
yeah and keep it alive for another five
years I want to do that yeah yeah and so
anyway look
this is always the puzzle yeah people
are going to cheat and the question is
can you build the set of rules in which
cheating doesn't result in you coming
out ahead if you don't do that then the
point is oh yeah let's learn what the
world of cheaters is going to look like
in 10 years because they're going to own
the system since nobody can compete with
them
animal mRNA vaccines under an NDA
Pfizer mRNA strands aren't uniform it is
cheaper to manufacture particle
distribution has an adjuvant effect
can't do that in animals
okay don't get the adjuvant claim here
and I don't know what can't do that in
animals means
let me read it again I work on the
animal mRNA vaccines under an NDA
the Pfizer mRNA strands are not uniform
it is cheaper to manufacture
particle distribution has adjuvant
effect can't do that in animals so so
hold on
I think I got it the only thing I don't
get is can't do that in animals of
course you can we're animals right so
maybe maybe it's a moral thing like
you're not allowed to
and it gives the opposite direction yeah
yeah so here's what I think is being
said there's certainly a thing Chris
Martinson has covered it covered it very
well a quality control issue where
basically
um people have done electrophoresis or
the equivalent and discovered that
you've got a whole bunch of different
size
mrnas which is it's just a molecular
technique by which you can tell the size
of molecules in a particular yeah it's a
quick and dirty assay because what you
basically do is you create an electric
charge that motivates things to move and
the rate at which they move is inversely
proportional to how long the sequence is
and so they separate themselves out and
you discover I mean the logic is kind of
intuitive like okay The more mass the
slower it's going to move the less far
it will move in x amount of time right
so anyway the idea is hey the cartoon
you showed me suggested that there was
going to be an mRNA have an exact length
and it was going to contain only these
messages and it turns out that's not
true a there's a lot of extra garbage on
the Strand that they've used because
there's a lot of molecular technique
into you know primers and sequences and
things that cause it not to be as
elegant a message as you would like and
then B you know your quality control and
production sucked and so you've got lots
of things that got halfway there and
then hiccuped and
um so particle particle distribution
meaning strands particle distribution
has adjuvant effect means then that all
these little bits that don't do the job
of
um that they are supposedly doing
effectively just like pokes at your
immune system and it gets it gets it to
wake up what it does is it gives your
immune system the sense of a lot of
hostility yeah and so an alert yeah um
so I could see that being a sort of
crude adjuvant that would then cause a
lot of response in the area
so all bad
can't do in animals what are you talking
about I I you know humans being animals
if you had it to rephrase how would you
rephrase it so we would understand what
it is that's actually different in
presumably non-human animals yep
here's the question and um it's related
to the other question that came in from
Discord this week
any thoughts on the Ohio train
derailment and the other hazardous
spills that followed that event thank
you both and much love and so
specifically the um
the Discord question framing was
um what are the evolutionary and
ecological impacts of the Ohio train
derailment and burn of the chemicals on
the surrounding environment
so a
completely horrifying and inevitable
right you're talking about some basic
compounds involved in industrial
processes in such large volumes that we
are transporting these things in the
open
every day
and trendy Romans happen because trains
are mechanisms and tracks are long and
weather occurs and nothing's perfect yep
in this particular case there's this
very dramatic video which you may have
seen from a CCTV camera where one of the
cars on the train that derailed was
sparking
miles before like the wheel or the
attraction you can imagine you've got a
train with 100 cars Each of which has
several axles sure some axle runs out of
Grease or a bearing brakes and so
something's rubbing that shouldn't be
rubbing and it heats up and gets ready
no one anywhere near it because it's a
long time through the night yeah you
know the only people manning the thing
are up front that's what I meant I don't
mean people on the people outside right
on the train there's only people up
front presumably apparently there are
detectors right this is a common enough
problem electronic electronic detectors
that mount near the tracks that are like
oh wait that wheel was hot okay you've
got a problem they send a signal okay so
part of the trainer part of the tracks I
think it's part of the track
infrastructure okay
um
but anyway
in this case the whatever system it is
didn't work thing derails which will
happen
then really weird [__] happens news
blackout we don't hear about this thing
until already we're at the point of them
having chosen to set a delays yeah all
of which is bad you know the uh vinyl
chloride
apparently you forgive me if my
chemistry is off here but you burn this
basically uh
this uh constituent of plastics this
chlorinated constituent of plastics you
burn it and one of the common products
is phosphine which is literally a
chemical warfare agent used in World War
one I think
um
fun but here's the here's the here's the
you know you've got the inevitable part
you've got the industrial part where
it's like oh you're using huge amounts
of this stuff that's built out of very
very toxic uh constituent molecules and
you've lost control of it totally
inevitable that will happen somewhere
right and then you didn't have a good
plan for what to do about it well that
wasn't inevitable right in fact given
that it was inevitable you were going to
spill this stuff
there should have been a you know
team that you could have anywhere in the
country within six hours that has the
right equipment to basically limit the
spread of this I don't know what it
would look like but you would you would
want to take all of the stuff that's
recoverable and you would want to
recover it into something that would
then allow you to neutralize it
chemically which didn't happen right
you've got some local fire department
you know scratching its head reading up
on what was on this train what's now
been spilled onto the ground and what
the dangers are
you've got what I suspect was a psyop in
which all of the semi-sophisticated
people were led to focus on this term
blevy right which is a kind of explosion
that you risk when you have a
pressurized liquid
um and you have an accident right where
it can cause these very powerful
explosions so yes you would if you were
on the ground you would be worried about
this possibility with these cars all
topsy-turvy having uh derailed
but the point is the fact that people
could look that up and then start
feeling sophisticated for saying it
cause them to kind of Miss what I
suspect is the story here which is
game theoretically there will be
repeatedly incidents where some
industrial thing has happened
the right thing to do to minimize the
amount of harm to human beings is X
but there's some other thing to do that
minimizes the legal liability while
increasing the harm to humans right so
one thing that is true is by lighting
the stuff on fire they have distributed
I think they've probably
greatly increase the number of
Cancers and other pathologies that
people will get from the same volume of
spilled liquid and they've distributed
that's part of the evolutionary and
ecological answer yeah they've
distributed it over a much bigger area
which means that it will be much harder
to find in other words if you had a
sky-high cancer rate in Palestine Ohio
then the answer is oh yeah it was that
spill there's no Three Mile Island right
and so or it yeah it's so I believe the
question is you always will have
industry looking for a mechanism once it
has caused its own legal liability to
distribute the harms so that they are
harder to spot and prove and I believe
that there are several examples of this
that we've seen in recent history one of
them being the Deepwater Horizon
accident
or you will recall there was a chemical
that none of us had heard of until the
accident called correx it
the oil companies had just long before
brexit yeah okay they had stored this
chemical so somehow the industry had
been sold this chemical that would deal
in some way with a oil spill oh it just
dispersed it all into little tiny
droplets in the Gulf of Mexico provide
it sank the oil so in some ways the
disaster was less horrible than it might
be because you didn't have as many
pictures of greasy Birds but it's still
like the floor of the Gulf of Mexico
like I don't know how deep it was there
but like the Abyssal zone or whatever is
just coated you can be pretty damn sure
what they didn't do is figure out that
the net harm was in order for using this
thing what they found out was hey
actually we can sink your oil for you
and then the lawsuits you'll face will
be a fraction of what you'd face
otherwise okay well there here we are in
the public suffering whatever harms that
is you know uh you know how's your
shellfish from the Gulf of Mexico
tasting right and then there's another
case
where during the Fukushima cleanup the
Japanese government played a couple of
different games
one game was it had a standard for how
much radioactivity meant you couldn't
burn waste
right very reasonable standard to have
now this is not chemical contamination
this is radioactive particles that are
not in any way
um rendered less Radioactive by burning
than they're just dispersed right so
what the Japanese government did was it
added material to waste that was too
radioactive to burn in order to get it
below the standard that would then allow
them to burn it which is insane all that
does up and then which way of the Winds
going did we get it on the west coast of
the U.S or did it go into Asia trucked
it around Japan as I recall no but the
but the the burn yeah
it went everywhere I don't know that
I don't know whether that plume reached
us lots of stuff from Fukushima did
reach us here on the West Coast
especially the Pacific Northwest
um but
the trucking of the material around
Japan means that the provability of the
harms will go down later this is the
original you and I talked at one point
on an early live stream about monkeying
with the Baseline yeah and the idea was
this will drive up the Baseline of
cancers elsewhere making whatever
increase happens in Fukushima prefecture
that much harder to see because the
background elsewhere is artificially
elevated
yeah
it's not dumb it's not a lack of
cleverness but anyway so what I would
say is I fear that what happened in
Palestine Ohio is
the result of business having gotten
wise to the fact that one way to deal
with its liability problem is to
distribute the harms over a larger
population so they're harder to prove
yep
uh the person who said they work with
the MRNA
vaccines under an NDA says they meant
not allowed to do in animals legally not
legally allowed to have oh interesting
Human animals well that would fit the
pattern of all kinds of things that
should never ever ever have been
injected into humans got injected into
humans in this case because of the
impression that we were in an emergency
and it had to be done yeah
everything
a 29 year old man from my church died
from a heart attack during a game of
pickup basketball this week he left
behind a young fiancee
I am angry
yeah
um all I can say is you'd be surprised
how often we get correspondence that
sound something like that
um and
yeah I I think it is really important
obviously there's some baseline level
of people dying anomalously even young
healthy people but it looks pretty clear
that this is not the Baseline level
and our deliberate avoidance of
establishing whether that is or isn't
true is more evidence that it is true
you know if this were really
our minds playing can we all agree that
it's in everyone's interest to figure it
out
right and why aren't we figuring it out
why aren't we figuring it out so why is
there apparently no move to figure it
out these people
I think I said months ago that I was
concerned that it felt like life
sometimes when you travel you realize
that life is very cheap where you've
landed then people suffer all kinds of
accidents because nobody is protecting
them yeah and that that is beginning to
feel true here too you know oh somebody
can deploy a so-called vaccine they can
mandate it on you you can collapse
during a pickup basketball game and it's
oh that's a shame another one
um
these people must not have died in vain
and you know almost the people who
took the vaccine because they thought it
was the right thing to do
and are now being gaslit over there uh
non-fatal
Adverse Events
these people all deserve a an accounting
of what happened and they deserve to
have what remains of our medical
establishment put at their disposal to
treat them yeah it's just the same that
we don't do it
um so hopefully hopefully the wins will
change
I don't know what this
question means multiple variant kovi uh
multiple variants SARS cov2 infections
remain acute and reactivate with new
infection question mark
try it again multiple variant Stars cov2
infections remain acute and reactivate
with new infection
um you know early in the pandemic we
talked about
all of the possibilities of what it
might turn out I think we can drop a
cute like acute doesn't it doesn't need
to be there right like remain like
latent latent is there is the word yeah
yeah I don't think we have the evidence
for this so yeah the concern was that
some but I also don't know for sure it
doesn't happen
it's hard to prove it doesn't ever
happen but we have I don't I think we
haven't seen
solid evidence that it has happened even
once it
I agree yeah but you know when in the
case of uh varicella and shingles you
know you're talking about many decades
that's true
so who's to say you know viruses hide
out especially in neurons
um
things happen and we did talk about this
possibility early on until we've seen in
you know
high quality evidence that says it's
happening I think it's a remote
possibility but
could be what we have definitely seen is
Coveted triggering other latent viruses
to re-emerge
yeah no for sure okay let's do a couple
more and then finish up for the week
Sean all right
did the covered vacs protect against
medical prejudice
unvaxed often did not receive care so if
you ended up at hospital there was
discrimination
that's that's interesting actually
that's sort of another way
um
that the unvaccinated numbers might not
be uh that the that the outcomes for
unvaccinated people who needed to seek
medical care
might not be entirely what they appear
because there was bias against them
by medical personnel
well I I admit I don't totally
understand the phrasing of the question
here but I will say it amplifies
the
point that you were making in the main
podcast about that terrible paper right
that's what I'm alluding to here because
even just at a self-selective level
point the people who are unvaccinated
are being demonized as you know the
cause or the the repository for the
virus right the bar how sick you have to
be before you seek medical attention
that bar goes way up and so the point is
the sickest of the sick would have
overcome that bar and shown up in that
study and that would of course buy us it
even more heavily yeah
this is this does not belong here this
belonged in the first in the main
podcast but it occurs to me that a
terrible study that we were talking
about
which didn't compare the populations it
claimed to
compared
a sample from all of the vaccinated
people to a sample from only those
people who were not vaccinated had covid
and had a positive covet test in the
medical situation
uh you know they had
three of the things that they were
looking at er visits hospitalizations
and deaths
they had the VAC the vaccinated you know
doing much better but it wasn't a fair
comparison and yet they had they showed
that natural immunity was better at
preventing infection than vaccination
was
and I made I made some offhand comment
in the first hour
about that even that still showed even
though they did this I think it actually
goes in the other direction let me try
to explain without visuals here
if what you have done is selected for
what might be the sickest of those who
had covid and were unvaccinated
um those are the people probably if if
basically that's that's going to be a
subset of entirely symptomatic people
those are the people most likely I would
expect to actually have really strong
natural immunity against future
infections whereas the people who'd had
covet and were asymptomatic might not
have such strong natural immunity going
forward that if you did if they did if
they had actually done the study right
if they had actually compared vaccinated
people a sample from all vaccinated
people to a sample from all unvaccinated
people who'd had covid
I predict that not only would those
other three measures hospitalizations ER
visits and deaths have been reversed
with regard to what uh we would have
seen but that the really big gap between
the vaccinated and those of natural
immunity might have been narrowed
because you would have had more people
in the unvaccinated but have had coveted
category who didn't have it bad and so
might not have generated as much natural
immunity and so you would have had more
future cases from that group actually
yeah there's that it also occurs to me
and again I didn't read the study so
yeah I don't I don't understand exactly
what they did but
um
it also strikes me that it would be very
difficult for them to establish that
those in their vaccinated group did not
also have covid and therefore they might
be counting a certain amount of
covid-based natural immunity in people
who happen to be vaccinated absolutely
so yeah you know the number of different
ones I don't remember any indication of
them trying to control for that at all
and of course they wouldn't have been
able to perfectly for exactly the same
reason that they didn't you know that
they actually sampled from not the
population they claimed to have which is
to say
a lot of people you know they had they
had no access to the data for people
who'd had coveted no they had coveted
but didn't tell anyone in the Health
Care system that they had covered right
and especially in light of the fact that
they did not give the obvious advice
don't get vaccinated if you've already
had covid right they should have no
quite the opposite there will be lots of
people in that cohort who had a good
natural immunity and it's counting in
favor of the vaccines isn't that
diabolical
right because oh man yeah that's that's
what really badly structured study so
bad
okay final question for this week do you
think animals feel pain in the same
manner we do is it hypocritical for
animal lovers to eat meat
um more closely related the animals are
to us
the more like our pain they experience
mammals experience
um pain in very similar ways across
mammals
um probably all vertebrates experience
very similar pain as far as we know does
that make it hypocritical hypocritical
for animal lovers to eat meat
no
uh
it
it would be hypocritical to uh to enjoy
meat from animals that were killed with
the intention of causing pain or with
indifference to it or with indifference
to it
um
but
understanding that the food that you are
eating had the capacity to experience
pain in life does not mean that you
should not eat it yeah and and hold on
there's one more thing before before you
go which is that um
there's just some work done by I said
let's say Temple Grandin
on figuring out how best to basically
feed cows into the killing chamber so
that they are the least freaked out at
the point that they that they are
slaughtered and
um basically you want them not to see
what's coming and not to hear what's
coming not to smell what's coming and
not to not to have them know that they
are being led to slaughter because
that's terrifying for anyone who has the
capacity to understand such things and
yes cows do
um so we think forward like we we think
ahead to oh that thing that I'm thinking
about doing is going to cause me pain
far more than anyone else does far more
than any other animal does although dogs
probably have some capacity for that
some other organisms you know many other
primates will have some capacity for
that
um but reducing the expectation of pain
and the actuality of pain as much as
possible in the slaughtering of the
animals that uh you intend to then use
for food and sustenance is is The Sweet
Spot
yeah uh there is a
sensitivity
to the idea of suffering that has become
unnatural and pathological
the two questions that you're asking
aren't really inherently related
yeah
right
animals feel pain I have no doubt that
there's almost nothing remarkable to say
within mammalia right and that's a very
wide group in terms of the different
ways that we all feel pain right there's
no reason for us
can you pre-exist that group so we've
just all inherited the same system
okay it's an interesting question
whether or not you know birds for
example which would be expected to have
similar use for the information feel it
the same way it's a very difficult
question to answer the brains are built
differently enough
um that I'll bet it's a little bit of
different mechanism stuff but basically
similar capacity yeah but look pain is
fascinating right you can get injured on
a battlefield and not really get in
touch with your pain until you get home
right why is that oh because it's not in
your interest right you need to get off
the damn Battlefield and feeling your
own suffering when what you need to be
doing is fighting your enemy in spite of
your broken arm right no you're going to
fight your enemy and you're and if you
have to ignore that you have a broken
arm even to the extent that you will
break it worse so that it will not heal
well right the priority is getting off
the battlefield so anyway pain is pain
is a means to an end
um
it has nothing really to do with the
question of whether or not it is Humane
to eat meat though as soon as you get to
factory farming I believe it again
becomes relevant and I would say that
factory farming is
immoral because it
needlessly inflicts suffering on animals
that occur until factory farming
effectively our partner
right it is a mutualism
the creatures that we eat actually have
a far better evolutionarily than their
wild counterparts right because by
traveling with us through time they
actually make it into the future whereas
their wild relatives are in danger of
going extinct because of what we're
doing to their habitats so anyway I
don't think it is in an animal's
interest to decide not to eat its
species
however we do a lot by hiding the way in
which we raise and Slaughter animals
from the people who do the eating which
is in part why we have this reaction of
like oh my God eating animals is
terrible
no raising animals in an inhumane way is
terrible and eating them and killing
them in an inhumane way is terrible
right and eating them and not thinking
about what the animal that you are
eating what kind of life it LED and
therefore you know allowing price to
drive you to hire someone to do inhumane
stuff to animals that you're going to
just try not to think about that's it
that's immoral so there's lots of moral
stuff here but it's not really about the
suffering of the animal right probably
we should be eating a lot less meat
cause
it wouldn't be economical if we raised
them all humanely
in other words if you're going to be an
animal and you're going to live not on a
feedlot you're going to live you know
you're going to have some you know range
over which you're going to graze
then the point is how many animals can
we do that with and so the point is
there is some interaction but it's not
the fundamental fact of eating meat it's
the way we raise meat and the way we
raise meat has been driven by economic
considerations into a frankly
indefensible and not very healthy mode
all right I think we did it I think
we're there we are there yeah yes and uh
they're not
they are there yeah it's different there
yes
moving Buck Reborns I write yet again
yep yet again yep what group bonsai was
like the uh
the the Donald philosopher of the eighth
Dimension yes
[Music]
all right uh we will see you next week
and until then be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
foreign